[Music]
welcome to the future of life institute
podcast i'm lucas perry today's episode
is with dr felipa lensos and explores
increasing global security concerns from
the use of the life sciences as
biotechnology continues to advance
the capacity for use of both the harmful
and beneficial aspects of this
technology is also increasing in a world
stressed by climate change as well as an
increasingly unstable political
landscape that is likely to include
powerful new biotechnologies capable of
killing millions
the challenges of biotech to global
security are clearly significant
dr lenzos joins us to explain the state
of biotech and life sciences risk in the
present day as well as what's needed for
mitigating the risk
dr felipe lensos is a mixed methods
social scientist with expertise in
biosafety biosecurity biorisk assessment
and biological arms control she works at
king's college london as a senior
lecturer in science and international
security
dr lenzos also serves as the co-director
of the center for science and security
studies is an associate senior
researcher at stockholm international
peace research institute and is a
columnist for the bulletin of atomic
scientists
her work focuses on transparency
confidence building and compliance
assessment of biodefense programs and
high-risk bioscience
she also focuses on information warfare
and deliberate disinformation related to
global health security
and with that i'm happy to present this
interview with dr felipa lensos
to start things off here
we've had kovid pretty much blindside
humanity
at least the general public people who
have been interested in pandemics and
biorisk have
known about this risk coming for
a long time now and have tried to raise
the alarm bells about it and it seems
like this other very very significant
risk is the continued risk of
synthetic bioagents
engineered pandemics and also the
continued risk of natural pandemics
and it feels to me extremely significant
and also difficult to convey the
the importance and urgency of this issue
especially when we pretty much didn't do
anything about covid and knew that a
natural pandemic was coming
so i'm curious if you could explain what
you think are the least understood
aspects of synthetic and
natural biological risk by the general
public and by governments around the
world and what you would most like them
to understand
i guess one of the key things to to
understand is that
security concerns of life science
research is something that we
must take seriously
there's this whole history of using the
life sciences to to cause harm of
deliberately inflecting disease
of developing biological weapons but
very few people know this history
because
it's a story that's suffused by secrecy
so in the 20th century biological
weapons were
researched and developed in several
national programs all of which were top
secret including the u.s one
these programs were concealed in labs at
military sites that were not listed on
ordinary maps
special code names and exceptionally
high classification categories were
assigned to biological agents and and
the projects that were devised to
weaponize them and bioweaponers were
sworn to secrecy and under constant
surveillance
so a lot of that just hasn't become
publicly available much of the
documentation and other evidence of past
programs
has been destroyed and there were these
concerted efforts to
bring war crimes and human rights abuses
to public light information about
biological weapons programs tended to be
suppressed so
one example of this
is the truth and reconciliation
commission hearings
in south africa that followed
the apartheid
so when the
commission
hearings began to uncover details about
south africa's biological weapons
program that was um called project coast
they were faced with delays and they
were faced with legal challenges and the
hearings were eventually shut down
before the investigators could complete
their work
now the head of that program
became obvious to the investigators at
the time who that was
but he was never brought to justice and
unbelievably
he remained a practicing medical doctor
for many many years afterwards possibly
even to this day and
what hasn't been concealed or destroyed
or silenced from past biological weapons
programs often remains
highly classified
so the secrecy surrounding past programs
mean that they they're not well known
but there's also
a new
contemporary context that shapes
security concerns about life science
research that we need to be
conscious
of and that i think
relates back to
what i think is important to know about
synthetic and natural bio risks
today
and that is that advances in in science
and technology
may enable biological weapons to emerge
that are actually more capable and more
accessible
with attacks that can be more precisely
targeted and are harder to
attribute
so synthetic biology for example which
is
one of the
currently
cutting edge areas of life science
research
that is accelerating our abilities to
manipulate genes and biological systems
and that will have all kinds of
wonderful and beneficial applications
but if the intent was there it could
also have significant downsides so it
could for instance
identify
harmful genes and dna sequences
in a much quicker way than we've been
able to so far as a result of that we
could for instance see greater potential
to make
pathogens or disease-causing biological
agents
even more dangerous
or
we could see greater potential to
convert low risk pathogens into high
risk pathogens
we could potentially re even
recreate extinct pathogens like the
variola virus
that causes
smallpox
or
um
way further out we could engineer
entirely new pathogens
now pathogens in and of themselves are
not biological weapons you need to add
some kind of delivery mechanism
to have a weapon the possibilities to
manipulate genes and biological systems
are coming at a time when new delivery
mechanisms for transporting pathogens
into our bodies into human bodies or
animal bodies are also being developed
so in addition to the bombs and the
missiles the cluster bombs the sprayers
and all kinds of injection devices of
past biological warfare programs
it could now also be possible to use
other delivery mechanisms so things like
drones or nano robots
these incredibly tiny robots that can be
inserted into our blood streams for
instance even insects could be used as
vehicles to disperse
dangerous pathogens
so i guess to get to
the bottom of your question what i'm
keen for people to understand
scientists government officials the
general public
is that current developments in science
and technology or in the life sciences
more specifically are are lowering
barriers to inadvertent harms
as well as to deliberate use and
development of biological weapons and
that there is this whole history
to deliberate attempts to use the life
sciences to cause harm
so it seems like there's three
main groups of people that are
interested in
such technology
so there's something like lone wolves or
isolated individuals who
are
interested in creating a lot of harm to
humanity in the same way that mass
shooters are there are also small groups
of people who may be interested in the
same sort of thing and then there's this
history of
governments pursuing biological weapons
could you offer some perspective about
the risks of these three groups and
how you would compare the current
technology
used for the creating of
synthetic
pathogens
to
how strong it was historically
sure are we heading towards a future
where anyone with a phd in
bioengineering could create a pandemic
and kill millions is that what you mean
well
a pathogen even a bioengineered one does
not on its own constitute a biological
weapon so you will still face issues
like agent stability and dealing with
large-scale production and importantly
dealing with efficient delivery which
is much easier said than done in fact
what the history of bioterrorism has
taught us
is that the skills required to undertake
even the most basic of bioterrorism
attacks are often much greater than
assumed
there are various technical barriers to
using biological agents to cause
harm
even
beyond the barriers that are being
reduced from advances in science and
technology
so
the data that is available to us from
past incidents of biological terrorism
indicates that a bioterrorism attack is
more likely to be crude more likely to
be amateurish and small scale where
you'd have casualty levels in single or
double digits and not in their hundreds
or thousands and certainly not in their
millions
now my own concern is actually less
about lone actors
where i see real potential for
sophisticated biological weapons and
strategic surprise
in the biological field is
in one of those other categories that
you mentioned it's so it's at the state
or or the state-sponsored level
so
let me explain well i already told you a
little bit about how we've recently seen
significant advances in genetic
manipulation and delivery mechanisms
so these developments are lowering
barriers to biological weapons
development
but that's really only part of the
picture because in making threat
assessments it's also important to look
at the social context in which these
technical developments are taking place
and one of the things we're seeing is
there in that social context is a build
up and do we use capacities
so what we're seeing is that
high containment labs
that are working with the most dangerous
pathogens are rapidly being constructed
all over the globe so there are now more
people and more research projects than
ever before
working with and manipulating very
dangerous pathogens and there are more
countries than ever before that have
biodefense programs
there's around 30
by defense programs that are openly
declared and
the trends we're seeing is that these
numbers are increasing
it's entirely legitimate to have
biodefense programs and they do a lot of
good
but
a side effect of increasing
biopreparedness and biodefense
capacities
is that capacities for causing harm
should the intent be there and that's
the crucial part also increase
so you may be doing one person may be
doing setting up all this stuff for good
but if somebody else comes in with
different intent with intent to do harm
that same infrastructure that same
material that same equipment that same
knowledge
can be turned towards causing harm or
creating biological weapons
now another thing we're seeing that
won't have escaped your notice
is the increasingly unstable and
uncertain geopolitical landscape the
world that many of us grew up in
and know is one in which america was a
clear dominant power we're now moving
away from that away from this hegemonic
or unipolar power structure towards an
international system that is
increasingly multi-polar
the most clearly rising power today is
of course china but there are others too
there's uh you know
russia's still there there's india
there's brazil to name a few
so those are things in the social
context that we need to pay attention to
we're also seeing rapidly evolving
nature of conflict and warfare
themselves
are changing and that's changing the
character of military challenges that
are confronting states hybrid warfare
for instance
which blends conventional warfare
with irregular warfare and cyber warfare
is increasingly likely to complement
classical military confrontation so
states that are increasingly outmatched
by conventional weapons may for instance
start to view novel biological weapons
as offering
some kind of advantage to some kind of
asymmetric advantage
and a possible way to outweigh
strategic imbalances
so
states
in this kind of
new form of conflict new form of warfare
may
see biological weapons as
somehow providing an edge or a military
advantage
we are also seeing the defense programs
of some states heavily investing in the
biological sciences
again
could well be for entirely legitimate
purposes
but it does also raise concerns that
adversaries may be looking
at those kinds of investments and
thinking hedging their bets and
similarly
investing
in
more
biological programs
these investments i think are also an
indication that there are some real
concerns that adversaries are harnessing
or trying to harness biotechnology for
for nefarious purposes and we've seen
some political language to that effect
too but a lot of this is going under the
radar
so all of these things um and they're
more you know they're the the flagrant
breach of the chemical weapons
convention or continuous flagrant
breaches of the chemical weapons
convention for example the use of
chemical weapons in syria or the use of
very sophisticated chemicals like
novichok in
in the uk on on the
skripal the
the the russian as well as other cases
is one other sort of context that plays
in or even our recent experiences of
natural disease outbreaks and here you
know covet is obviously a
key example but it's not so long ago
we've had all kinds of other outbreaks
ebola just a few years ago there's zika
there's murders there's all kinds of
other emerging diseases so all of these
could serve to focus attention on
deliberate outbreaks
and all of these various elements of the
social
context as well as these
technical
uh developments could produce an
environment in which a potential
military or
political utility
for biological weapons emerges that
alters the balance of incentives and
disincentives to comply with internet
than in the international treaty that
prohibits biological weapons
could you explain the incentives of why
a country would be interested in
creating a synthetic pathogen
when
inevitably it would seem like it would
come back and harm itself
well it doesn't have to be an infectious
pathogen
what we're seeing today with with covet
for instance is an infectious pathogen
that spreads uncontrollably throughout
the world but states don't have to
and not all dangerous pathogens are
infectious in that way
anthrax for instance doesn't spread from
from person to person through the air
you know and so there are different
kinds of pathogens
and states and non-state actors
will have different
motivations
for using biological weapons
or biological agents one of those which
i mentioned earlier is for instance if
you
feel that another country you are
outmatched conventionally by
conventional weapons you may want to
start to
develop asymmetric weapons just that
would be
an example where
a state might want to
explore
developing biological weapons but of
course we should probably mention that
there is this thing called the
biological weapons this international
treaty which completely prohibits this
class of weaponry
and historically there's really only
been two
major powers that have developed
sophisticated biological weapons
programs and that is the united states
and the soviet union
today
there are no
publicly available documents or
any
policy statements
suggesting that anyone has an offensive
biological weapons program there are
many countries who have defensive
programs and that's entirely legitimate
there's no indication that there are
states that have offensive programs
to date i think
the real concern is about capacities
that are building up through
by defense programs
but also through regular bio
preparedness programs and that's
something that's just going to increase
in future
so i i'm curious here if you could also
explain and expand upon the particular
strands of your research efforts in this
space
sure i mean it's very much related to
the sorts of things we've been talking
about so one strand that i focus on and
relates to transparency confidence
building and compliance assessment of
biodefense programs
where i look at how we can build trust
between different countries with
biodefense programs to
trust that they are complying with the
biological weapons convention
i'm also looking at transparency around
particular high-risk bioscience so
things or
projects like
or research
involving genome editing for example or
potentially pandemic pathogens like
influenza or coronaviruses
another strand that i'm interested in or
that i'm looking at
focuses on emerging technologies
and on governance around these emerging
technologies and and and on responsible
innovation and there i look particularly
at synthetic biology um also a little
bit at artificial intelligence deep
learning and robotics how this is
these
other emerging areas are coming into the
life sciences and affecting their
development and
the direction they're taking the
capacities that are emerging from this
kind of convergence between emerging
technologies and how we can
govern
that better how we can have provide
better oversight now one of the projects
that i've been involved in that has got
a lot of press recently is a study that
i carried out with greg coblins at
george mason university
where we mapped
high bio containment laboratories
globally so i mentioned earlier that
countries around the world are investing
in these kinds of labs to study lethal
viruses and to prepare against unknown
pathogens while that construction boom
has to date resulted in dozens of these
commonly called bsl4 labs
around the world now significantly more
countries are expected to build these
kinds of labs in the wake of covet 19 as
part of a renewed emphasis on pandemic
preparedness and response
in addition gain of function research
with coronaviruses and other zoonotic
pathogens with pandemic potential is
also likely to increase as scientists
are seeking to better understand these
viruses and to assess the sorts of risks
that they pose of jumping from animals
to humans or
becoming transmissible between humans
now of course clinical work and
scientific studies on pathogens
are
really important for
public health and for disease prevention
but
some of these activities
pose really significant risks
and surges in the number of labs and
expansion the high risk research that's
carried out within them
exacerbate safety and security risks
but
there is no authoritative international
resource
tracking the number of labs of these
kinds of labs out there as they're being
built so there is no international body
that has an authoritative
figure on the number of bsl4 labs that
there that exist in the world or that
have been established and equally there
is no
real international
oversight of the sort of research that's
going on in these labs or the sorts of
biosafety and biosecurity measures that
they have implemented so what our study
did
was to provide a detailed interactive
map of bsl4 labs worldwide that
contained basic information on when they
were established on the size of the labs
and some indicators of biorisk
management oversight that map is
publicly available
online at
globalbiolabs.org
so you can go and see for yourself and
it's basically a very large google map
where the labs are indicated and you can
scroll over the labs
and then up
pops information about when it was
established how big it is what sorts of
biorisk management indicators
there are so are they members of
national biosafety associations
do they have regulations
related to biosafety
do they have codes of conduct etc those
kinds of things that all comes up there
so you can go and see for yourself
that's a resource that we've made
publicly available on the basis of our
project and looking at the data we then
collated this was really the first time
this kind of concerted effort was
made to
identify these various labs and bring
all that information
together
and some of our key findings from
looking at that data where that well the
first thing is
the bsl4 labs are booming we can see a
really quite steep increase in the
number of labs that have been built over
the last few years
we found that there are now um
that there are many more public health
labs than there are biodefense labs so
about 60 of the labs are our public
health
labs and not focused on on defense but
on resourced out of health budgets
we also found that there are many uh
smaller labs and larger labs so
in newspapers and on tv we keep seeing
photos of the wuhan institute of
virality's bsl4 lab that's very much
tied up into the origins debate and
constantly featured in the media so that
is the sort of lab that we're talking
about and that image will often
be the one that pops into people's head
when you're talking about buy safety by
high by containment labs or bsl4 labs
in terms of oversight some of our other
findings were that
sound biosafety and biosecurity
practices do exist but they're not
widely adopted so there's a lot of
difference in between the kinds of by
safety and biosecurity measures that
labs
adopt and implement
we also found that assessments to
identify life science research
that could harm uh health safety or
security uh are lacking in the vast
majority of
countries that have these bsl4 labs so
as i said that's one of the studies
that's get a lot of press recently and
and
part of that is because of its
relationship to the current pandemic and
the lack of you know some solid
information some solid data and on the
sort of labs that are out there and on
the sorts of research that's being done
do you have a favorite story of a
particular time that a
bsl lab
failed to contain some important
pathogen
well there are all kinds of examples of
accidental releases
in the uk for instance
where i am based a very long time ago
there was a
work with variola virus
that causes smallpox was worked at a in
a in a sort of high-rise building
that had multiple floors
and the
variola virus escaped into the floor
above
and infected as somebody there so that
was the very last time
that was i think at the end of the 70s
so that was the very last time
that
someone was infected by smallpox and in
the uk more recently in the uk there's
also been the escape of the foot and
mouth
virus
from a lab now this was not the
very large foot and mouth
outbreak
that we had in the early 2000s
but it came
which you know killed millions of
animals and i still remember
the pyres of
animal corpses
dotted around the country
and
you could still smell that the burning
carcasses on the motorway as you drove
past etc so
that was not caused by a lab leak but
just a few two three four years later
there was a foot and mouth disease virus
that escaped from a lab through a
leaking pipe that did go on to cause
some infections but at that stage
um everyone was very primed to look out
for
in these kinds of infections and to
respond to them quickly so that outbreak
was contained fairly rapidly i mean
there are also many examples um
elsewhere also in the united states i
mean the
there's the the one for that one example
where you had a variola virus found in a
disused closet
at the nih um after many years and they
were still viable i think that's one of
the ones that rank pretty highly in the
biosafety community's memory
and maybe even in your own it was not
that long ago half a dozen years ago or
so
what do you think all these examples
illustrate of
how humans should deal with
natural and synthetic pathogens
well
i think it illustrates that we need
better oversight we need better
governance to ensure that the life
science research that's done is done
safely it's done securely and it's done
responsibly
overviewing all these these bsl
safety labs and all these different
research threads that you're exploring
what do you think is the most pressing
issue in in biosecurity right now
something that you'd really like
the government or the public to to to be
aware of and take action on
well i think there's a a really pressing
need to shore up international norms and
treaties that prohibit biological
weapons
i mentioned the biological weapons
convention and that is the
key
international instrument for
prohibiting biological weapons but there
are also others and the
arms control communities
is not in great shape at the moment it
needs
more
um
high profile political attention it it
needs more resources and i think with
more and more breaches that we're seeing
not on the biological side but on other
sides breaches of international treaties
i think we need to make sure
there is this renewed effort and
commitment to these
treaties so i think that's one
one thing one issue that's really
pressing in biosecurity right now
another is really raising awareness
and increasing sensitivities in
scientific communities to
you know potentially accidental or
inadvertent or deliberate risks of the
life sciences and and you know we see
that very clearly in the data that's
coming out of the esl4 study that i
talked to you about um that that's
something that that that's needed
not just what we saw there is as
actually looking at do they have any
books you know
laws in the books or do they have any
guidance on paper do they have any
written down codes of conduct or codes
of practice
and that's really important it's really
important to have these kinds of
instruments in place but it's equally
important to make sure that these are
implemented and adopted and that there
is this culture of
safe secure and responsible science and
that's not that's something that we
didn't cover in that specific project
but it's something that some of my other
work has drawn attention to and and the
work of many others as well so so we do
need to have this regulatory oversight
governance framework in place but we
also need to make sure that that is
reflected or echoed in the culture
of the scientists and and the labs that
are carrying out uh life science
research
one other significant
thing going on in the in the life
sciences
in terms of biological risk is gain of
function research so i'm curious if you
could explain what gain of function
research is and
how you see the debate around the
benefits and risks of it
well gain of function is actually a very
good example of life science research
that could be accidentally
inadvertently or deliberately misused
gain of function means
different things to different people
so to virologists it generally
just means genetic manipulation
that results in some sort of
gained function
most of the time you know these
manipulations result in loss of function
but sometimes um
different kinds of functions of
pathogens can be gained
gain of function has got a lot of media
coverage in relation to the origins of
the discussion around the origins of the
pandemic or of covet
and here gain of function is generally
taken to mean deliberately making a very
dangerous
pathogen like influenza or coronavirus
even more dangerous so what you're
trying to do is you're trying to make it
spread more easily for example or you're
trying to change
its lethality i don't think gain of
function research in and of itself
should be banned
but i do think we need better national
and international oversight of function
experiments
and i do think that a wider group of
stakeholders
beyond just the scientists doing the
research themselves and their funders i
think that a wider group of stakeholders
should be involved in assessing what is
safe what is secure and what is
responsible gain of function research
it seems very significant especially
with all these examples that you've
illustrated of the fallibility of bsl
labs
the you know gain a function research
seems incredibly risky relative to the
potential payoffs
yeah i think that's right i mean i think
it is
considered one
of the extra examples of what has been
called dual use research of concern or
experiments that
have
a
higher potential
to
be misused and by that i mean
deliberately but also in terms of
inadvertently or even accidentally
because the repercussions the
consequences have the potential to be so
large and that's also why we saw when
some of the early
gain of function
experiments
gained
media attention back in 2011 2012 that
the scientific community itself reacted
and and
said well we need to have a moratorium
we need to have a pause
on this kind of research to think about
how
we
govern
that how we provide sufficient oversight
over the sorts of work that's being done
so that
the risk benefit assessments
are better
essentially
i think there will be many who argue
that
myself among them
um that the discussion that was had
around getting a function at that time
were not extensive enough they were not
inclusive enough there were not enough
voices
being heard or
part of the decision-making process
in terms of the policies that came out
of this in the united states
and to some extent i think that's why
we're again back at the table now with
the discussions around the pandemic
origins
do you have any particular examples of
of gain of function research you'd be
interested in in sharing it seemed like
a really significant example was what
was happening
in wisconsin
sure and that was the one that was
the work in in wisconsin and at the
erasmus
university in in in the netherlands
what they were trying to do there was to
um they were working with uh influenza
or avian flu and they were
seeing if they were able to
give that virus a new function so enable
it to spread not just among
birds
but also
from birds to mammals
including humans including ourselves so
they were actively trying to make it not
just affect birds but also to affect
humans and and they did so successfully
which made that virus um more dangerous
and that was what that media furor was
about and the you know the discussions
at the time
were that
many felt
that the benefits of that research did
not outweigh the very significant
potential risks the very significant
risks
that that research
involved
what are the benefits of that sort of
gain of function research
well the ones that carry it out there
that sort of research
both at the time but also the sorts of
gain of function we've researched that's
been going on at the women institute of
virology that's been
some of it which has been funded by
american
money some of it which has been done in
collaboration with american institute
argues that
in order to prepare for
pandemics
we need to know
what kind of viruses are going to hit us
and so
new and emerging
viruses generally come spill over from
the animal
kingdom into
humans so they actively
go and look for viruses
in the animal kingdom in this case in
coronavirus case the wound instead of
rlg they were actively looking in bat
populations to see what sort of viruses
exist there and what their potentials
are for spilling over into humans so
that's their justification for doing
that
my own view is that
that's incredibly risky research and i'm
not sure
and i don't feel that that sort of
justification
really outweighs the very significant
risks that it involves
it's like finding a you know a needle in
a haystack how can you possibly
hit upon the right
virus in the thousands and thousands of
viruses that are out there and know how
that will then mutate and modify get
modified as it hits the
human population
these are really significant and and
quite serious viruses so you explained
an example earlier about this uk case
right where the final people to die from
smallpox was actually from a bsl lab
leak and so there's also this research
in wisconsin on avian flu
so could you provide a little bit of a
perspective on for example the the
infection rate and case fatality rate of
these kinds of viruses that they're
working on at bsl labs that they have at
bsl labs that they might be pursuing
gain of function research on
yeah i mean certainly in terms of the
coronavirus what we've seen there is
that that is
clearly
many people have died
many people have got infected but that's
not
considered a particularly infectious
or particularly lethal
pathogen when it comes to pandemics so
we've seen much more
dangerous pathogens that could create
pandemics or that are being worked with
in laboratories
yeah
because you know some of these diseases
it seems the case fatality rate gets up
to
you know between 10 and
30 percent right and so if you're doing
gain of function research on something
that's already that lethal and that has
killed hundreds of millions of people
you know in the history of life on earth
that with the history of lab leaks and
with uh you know something so infectious
and and spreadable it seems like
one of the most risky things humanity is
doing on the planet currently
yes i mean one of the things that gain
and function doing it is doing it is
looking at lethality and how to increase
lethality of pathogens there are also
other things that gain a function um is
doing
but that is
kind of taking out a large part of the
equation which is the social context of
how viruses spread and mutate there are
for instance things we can do to make
viruses spread less and be less lethal
there are active measures we can take
equally there are
responses that could increase
the effect of viruses and how they
spread and so
lethality is one aspect
a potential pandemic but it's it but it
is only one aspect right there are these
many other aspects too so we
need to
think of ourselves much more as active
players that that we also have a role to
play in how these viruses spread and
mutate
one thing the the digital revolution has
brought in is the increase and you know
the the birth of big data
so
big data can be used to detect the the
beginning of outbreaks to detect
novel diseases and to you know come up
with cures and
treatments for
novel and existing diseases so i'm
curious what your perspective is on the
benefits and risks of the increase of
big data in biology both to
health and society as well as
privacy and the like
well you you pointed to many of the
benefits that that the big data
has and there certainly are benefits but
as with most things there are also
a number of downsides and i do believe
that big data combined with the advances
that we're seeing in genomic
technologies as well as with
other areas of emerging technology so
machine learning or ai
this poses a significant
threat it will allow
an ever more refined record of our
biometrics
so our fingerprints our iris scans our
face recognition our
you know cctv cameras that
can pick up individuals based on how
they walk all these kinds of biometrics
it will also
allow a more refined record of our
emotions
and behaviors to be
captured and to be
analyzed i mean you will have heard of
companies that are now using
facial recognition on their employees to
see whether they're
what kind of mood they're in
and how they engage with clients etc
so
governments are are you know gaining
incredible powers here but increasingly
it's private companies that are gaining
this sort of power so
what i mean by that is that governments
but as i said increasingly private
companies will be able to sort um to
categorize to trade and to use
um biological data far more precisely
than they have ever been able to do
before and that will create
unprecedented possibilities for social
and biological control
particularly through
individual surveillance if you like so
these game-changing developments will
deeply impact how we view health
how we treat disease
how long we live and how
more generally we consider our place on
the biological continuum i think they'll
also radically transform the jewel used
nature of biological research of
medicine of healthcare
and
in terms of my own field of biosecurity
they will create the possibility of
novel biological weapons that target
particular groups
of people
and even individuals now i don't mean
they will target americans or they will
target brits or they will target
protestants or they will target jews or
they will target muslims
that's not how biology works
genes don't understand these
social categories that we put on to
people that's how we socially divide
people up but that's not how
genetics divides people up but there are
groupings also genetically
that that go across
cultures nations uh beliefs etc so as we
come to have more and more precise
biological data on these different
groups
the possibility of
targeting these groups for harm
will also be
realized
so in the coming decade managing the
fast and broad technological advances
that are now underway will require new
kinds of governance structures that we
need to put in place and these new
structures need to draw on individuals
and groups with cross-sectoral
experience so from business from
academia
from politics from defense
from intelligence and so on to identify
emerging security risks and to make
recommendations for dealing
with them so we need new kinds of
governance structures new kinds of
advisory bodies that
have different kinds of stakeholders on
them to the ones that we have
traditionally had so in terms of big
data and the international community
with the continued
risks of
natural pandemics as well as synthetic
pandemics or other kinds of biological
agents and warfare it's been proposed
for example to create something like
a bio weather map
where we have an a widespread globally
distributed
early warning detection system for
biological agents that is based off of
big data or is itself
big data
so i'm curious if you have any any any
perspective and thoughts on
the importance of of big data in
particular for
defenses against the modern risks of
engineered and natural pandemics
yes i do think there is a role to play
here for
data analysis tools of big data we are i
think uh already using some tools in
this area where you have for instance
analysis of social media usage and words
that pop up on social media uses or you
have analysis of
the sorts of products that people are
buying in pharmaceutical companies so if
there is
some kind of disease spreading
people are getting sick and they're
talking about different kinds of
symptoms you're able to kind of start
tracking that you're able to start
mapping that all of a sudden
all kinds of people in say nebraska are
going to the pharmacy to buy
cough medicine or
or
something to reduce temperature or
you know there's a big spike for
instance you might want to look into
that more that's an indicator that you
there's a signal they might want to look
at that more or if
you're picking up keywords
on internet searches or on social media
where people are asking about
you know stomach cramps or you know more
specific kinds of symptoms that again is
another
kind of signal
you might want to look
more into that or if there is
so so i think some of these tools are
are definitely already being developed
some are already in use and i think
they will have advantages and benefits
in terms of preparing for
both natural but also inadvertent
accidental or deliberate outbreaks of
disease
we're hopefully in the
final stages of the
covid19 pandemic
and
you know when we reflect back upon it it
seems like it can be understood as
a kind of almost like a minimally viable
global catastrophe or minimally viable
pandemic because there's been far worse
pandemics
for example in the past
and you know
it's tragically taken the lives of of
many many people
but at the same time the you know the
fatality rate is
just a bit more than the flu and a lot
less than many of the other pandemics
that humanity has seen
you know in the past
few hundred thousand years
so
i'm curious what your perspective is on
on what we can learn in the areas of
scientific social
political and global life
from our experience with the kovit 19
pandemic to
be better prepared for something that's
more serious in the future something
that's more infectious and
has a higher case fatality rate
well i think as you said you know
in the past disease has been much more
present
in
our societies
it's really with the rise of
antibiotics and the rise of you know
modern health care that we've been able
to
suppress
disease to the extent that it's no
longer such a
pressing feature in our daily lives and
i think what the pandemic has done to
a whole generation is really just it has
been a shot across the bow
really crystallize the incredibly
damaging effects that disease
can have on society it's been this
wake-up call or this reality check and
and i i think we've seen that reflected
also
politically so
international developments like the the
un's
biorisk working group that's been
established by the secretary general we
or our efforts by states to develop a
new international treaty on pandemics
are concrete evidence of increasing
awareness of the challenges that
diseases pose to humankind
but clearly
that's not enough we
well it hasn't been enough what we've
had in place so
clearly we need to be better prepared
and i guess for me that's one of the
bigger takeaways from
um the pandemic
equally what
the pandemic origin debate has done is
to show that whether or not the pandemic
resulted from a lab leak
it could have
resulted from a lab leak it could
ironically
or tragically
have been the result of scientific
research
actually aimed at preventing future
pandemics so
clearly for me a huge takeaway is that
we need better oversight we need better
governance structures to
ensure safe secure and responsible life
science research
potentially
we also need to rethink some of our
preparedness strategies you know maybe
actively
hunting for
viruses in the wild
mutating them in the lab to see if that
single virus might be the one that hits
us next the one that spills over
isn't the best strategy for preparing
for pandemics in the future
butkovitz also highlighted a more
general problem one i think that's faced
by all governments and that is how can
we successfully predict and prepare for
the wide range of threats that there are
to citizens international security and
some threats like covet 19 are largely
anticipated actually
but they're not adequately planned for
as we've seen other threats are not
anticipated at all and for the most part
are not planned for
and
the other side some threats are planned
for but they fail to materialize as
predicted because of errors and biases
in the analytic process
so
we know that governments have long tried
to forecast or to employ a set of
futures approaches to ensure
they are ready for the next crisis
in practice these are often general
they're ad hoc they're unreliable
they're methodologically and
intellectually weak and they lack
academic insight and the result is
that governments are wary of building on
the recommendations of much of this
futures work um they avoid it in policy
planning in real terms funding and
ultimately in practice and
institutionalization
so what i and many of my colleagues
believe is that we need a new vision of
strategic
awareness that goes beyond the simple
idea of just providing a long-term
appreciation of the range of
possibilities that the future might hold
to one that includes communication with
governments
about their receptivity to intelligence
how they understand intelligence how
they absorb other kinds of intelligence
from private corporations from academia
etc as well as the manner in which the
government acts as a result so strategic
awareness to to my mind and to that of
many others should
should therefore be conceptualized in in
three ways you should first look more
seriously and closely
at threats
second you should invest in prevention
and four-sided
action and third you should prepare for
mitigation crisis management and bounce
back in case a threat can't be
fully prevented or deterred
this kind of thinking about strategic
awareness
will require a paradigm shift in how
government practices strategic awareness
today
and my view is that the academic
community must play an integral part in
that
do you have any particular
governance solutions that you're really
excited about right now
i don't think there's a magic bullet i
don't think there's one magic solution
to
ensuring
that life science research is is safe um
that it's secure and that it's carried
out responsibly i think
in terms of governance we need to work
both from the top down and from the
bottom up so we need to have in place
both
national laws and regulations um
statutory laws and regulations we need
to have in place institutional guidance
we need to have in place
best practices
but we also need
a lot of the commitment we also need a
lot of
awareness
coming from the bottom up so we need
individual scientists groups of
scientists
to
think about
how their work can best be carried out
safely
so they can make
codes of ethics or culture practice
themselves they can educate others they
can think through
how
who needs to be involved
beyond their own expert community in
risk assessing the kinds of research
that they're interested in
carrying out so we need
both this top-down government-enforced
institutionally enforced
governance as well as grassroots
governance and only by having
both of these aspects
both of these kinds of governance
measures can we really start to to
address
the potential downsides of life science
research
all right just to to wrap things up i'm
curious if you have any final words or
thoughts for for the audience or anyone
that that might be listening anything
that you
feel is sort of a crucial takeaway on
this issue i i generally feel that it's
really difficult to convey the uh
the significance and and gravitas and uh
you know importance of this so i'm
curious if you have any and you know any
final words about about this issue or a
really central key takeaway you'd like
listeners to have
i think when we're looking at our
current century this will be
the century not of
chemistry or physics or engineering
we've that was last century this will be
the century of biology and it will be
the century of
digital information
and of ai
and i think this combination
which we talked about earlier when you
when you combine
biological data with
machine learning with ai with genomic
technologies
you get incredible potential
of precise information about individuals
i think that is something we are going
to struggle with
in the years to come and we need to make
sure
that that we are aware
of what is happening that we are aware
that we and when we pick then we go by a
phone and we use the face recognition
software which is brilliant
that it can also have downsides and all
these little individuals actions all
these
technologies that we just readily accept
because they do have upsides in our life
they can also have potential downsides
and i do think we need to make sure we
also develop this
critical sense
or this ability to be critical
think critically about what these
technologies are doing to us as
individuals
and to us as
societies so i guess that is the things
i would like people to take away from
our discussion
all right
well
thank you so much for coming on the
podcast i i really can't think of uh too
many other issues that are that are as
important as this it's it's certainly
top three for me thank you very much for
for all of your work on this dr lensos
and for all of your time here on the
podcast
thanks for having me lucas
thanks for joining us
if you found this podcast interesting or
useful consider sharing it on social
media with friends and subscribing on
your preferred podcasting platform
we'll be back again soon with another
episode in the fli podcast
[Music]